je n'ai qu'un objectif 800 l'âge était
de pouvoir devenir un grand écrivain
tu vas devoir arrêter ce genre de saint
géry
c'est sûr que mon rallye terre c'est une
sauvageonne
conduire à cette famille à sa perte le
sait pas se tenir comme une jeune fille
bien élevée
[Musique]
merci
si j'étais avec toi
elle devrait être
notre luxe
[Musique]
et mary du canada
une femme doit recevoir une éducation
qui ne devrait pas être la même que
celle ci nous enseignent comment tourner
le monde
ils ont par contre je ne sais pas
comment vous faites pour tenir à deux
dans un livre ses petits aléas
je n'ai qu'un objectif c'est de pouvoir
devenir un grand écrivain et il n'y a
rien que vous puissiez faire pour mes
péchés
oh mon dieu elle est vraiment folle bien
sûr qu'elle est folle c'est emilie dit
on faire tu vas devoir arrêter ce genre
de saint jacques
je fasse quelque chose aux maux des
espèces
tu pas comme une morte alors que tu es
en vie
si vous voulez obtenir quelque chose
vous devez tendre la main et vous en
emparer
cette forte est et sera la salle
dickinson dont on parlera dans 200 ans
je dois fait la promesse c'était quand
même un très bel enterrement
on évoque le mien